[Music]
when we come to artificial intelligence
and the possibility of their becoming
conscious we reach a profound
philosophical difficulty
I am a philosophical naturalist I am
committed to the view that there is
nothing in our brains that violate the
laws of physics there's nothing that
could not in principle be reproduced in
technology it hasn't been done yet we're
probably quite a long way away from it
but I see no reason why he shouldn't
reach the point where a human-made robot
is capable of consciousness and a
feeling pain we can feel pain why
shouldn't they and this is profoundly
disturbing because it kind of goes
against the grain to think that that a
machine made of metal and silicon chips
could feel pain but I don't see why they
would not and so that this moral
consideration of how to treat
artificially artificially intelligent
robots will arise in the future and it's
a problem which philosophers and moral
philosophers are already talking about
once again and I'm committed to the view
that this is possible I'm committed to
the view that anything that a human
brain can do can be replicated in
silicon and so I'm sympathetic to the
misgivings that have been expressed by
highly respected figures like Elon Musk
and Stephen Hawking
that we ought to be worried that on the
precautionary principle we should worry
about a takeover perhaps even by robots
by our own creation especially if they
reproduce themselves and potentially
even evolved by reproduction and don't
need us anymore this is a a
science-fiction speculation at the
moment but I think philosophically I'm
committed to the view that it is
possible and like any major advance we
need to apply the precautionary
principle and ask ourselves what the
consequence
is might be it could be said that the
sum of not human happiness but the sum
of sentient being happiness might be
improved they might make a better job do
a better job of running the world than
we are certainly than we are at present
and so perhaps it might be the bad thing
if we went extinct and our our
civilization our the memory of
Shakespeare and Beethoven and
Michelangelo persisted in silico rather
than in brains and and our form of life
and one could foresee at future time
when silicon beings look back on a dawn
age when when the earth was peopled by
soft squishy watery organic beings and
who knows that might be better but we're
really in the science fiction territory
now
[Music]